Hollywood films are built on three
components character desire and conflict
yes they are
okay so Hollywood films any other types
of films art house films I know we
talked about briefly off-camera it's the
same rules apply but maybe just
different elements that the characters
yeah in that case there's nothing
different at all and we're not just
talking about movies that's the
foundation of all story okay any story
you can talk about epic poem you can
talk about a myth you can talk about a
fairy tale or children's book they're
all built on character desire and
conflict every story that I can think of
almost without exception if it's a
narrative story that I was a beginning
middle and end it's going to be about a
character who desperately wants
something and something stands in their
way and you say the desire moves the
story along but actually what we
resonate with is conflict I'm seeing the
conflict is what more is more
responsible for the emotion that is
elicited because let me give it as an
example the movie well let's say let's
let me put it this way let's say I said
to you you want to go to a movie this
weekend and you said well what are we
going to see and I said well I heard
about this movie it's about a guy who
wants to make a speech so what do you
think well chances are although I know
you're into our house movies you're
probably gonna say yeah what else is
playing cuz watching a guy give a speech
you can do that on TV
and be bored to tears anytime but if I
said it's a story about a guy who wants
to give a speech and he happens to be a
prince in Great Britain who has a horrid
speech impediment who was abused as a
child who has no desire for the throne
but then has to become king when his
brother abdicates and the speech he
wants to give is going to be the speech
that leads his country into World War
two
no no it's sounding not only intriguing
it sounds like it could be an Oscar
winner because all of those things I
just said where all of the conflict he
faces in trying to give the speech so
it's not giving the speech that makes
that story exciting or emotional or
appealing or commercial it's the
obstacles he had to come
overcome to do that let's take desire so
in something like fatal attraction which
I know is an extreme version of desire
the desire is not really what's moving
the story along it's the conflict in
terms of no no it's the desire is moving
it forward but you have to pinpoint what
you first of all who's the hero of the
movie the hero is the Michael Douglas
character okay and at the set up we meet
him and he's restless and not a very
moral guy and sort of you know whatever
and then he meets as the opportunity he
meets Glenn Close I don't remember the
character's name and has an affair with
her and starts doing that so somewhere
around the one-quarter mark I think he's
already going to bed with her but then
we see that she might be a little more
possessive than he was anticipating and
gradually the more her craziness and
possessiveness and psychosis starts
coming to the fore the more he wants to
get away from her and and finally
stopped her from terrorizing him and his
family
so actually his outer motivation is to
stop the crazy woman he slept with from
terrorizing or destroying his family and
if you realize the goal is to stop her
then his desire to do that pushes that
story forward now admittedly it's her
actions that he must react to that are
moving things forward just as much so
he's reactive more than proactive in a
way but what we're rooting for is for
him to get away from this crazy woman
before everything goes kablooey because
even though he made a big mistake we
still are rooting for him
you